نقلت رويترز عن هيئه الاركان الكوريه
الجنوبيه نا كوريا الشماليه اطلقت صاروخين
بالستهين باتجاه الساحل الشرقي لشبه
الجزيره الكوريه
الاذاعه والتلفزيون اليابانيه نقلا عن
مسؤولين ان الصاروخان بالي الصين اطلقته
كوريا الشماليه سقط خارج المنطقه
الاقتصاديه الخالصه لليابان ياتي اطلقه
الصاروخين بعد ايام فقط من الاختبار الذي
اجرته بيونكينج على محرك يعمل بالوقود
الصلب بقوه كبيره يقود الخبراء انه سيسمح
باطلاق اسرع اطلاقا اسرع للصواريخ
البالستيه
تنمو الينا من طوكيو مراسله الجزيره مها
منصوره مها مرحبا بك معنا اذا ما هي
المواقف في طوكيو من تصاعد هذه التجارب
نعم قامت كوريا الشماليه اليوم باطلاق
صاروخين
ثمان ساعات 11 بفاصل
25 دقيقه يبدو انهما سقطاع خارج المنطقه
الاقتصاديه الخالصه لليابان مع عدم ذكور
اي اضرار
بجانب الياباني جراءه هذه الصواريخ
هذه منذ بدايه في هذا العام يبدو ان هذه
الصواريخ ثم اطلاقها للمره السادسه
والثلاثين بالنسبه للموقف الياباني لم يكن
هناك همم ادانه حتى الان بشكل رسمي همم من
الحكومه اليابانيه ويبدوا حسب الخبراء بان
ليون غاضبه او ساقطه على ما قامت به
اليابان من تبني وثائقي امن القوميه جديده
نهار الجمعه حيث تدعوا فيها للحصول على
الرد همم او همم
الهجوم المضاد القدره على مهاجمه قواعد
اطلاق صواريخ العدو العدو كما يبدو ان
بيونجا ايضا غاضبه مما قررته جمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده نهار الجمعه في ما يخص
انتهاكات كوريا الشماليه لحقوق الانسان
شكرا